Speaker 1: We're continuing to hear from folks
in the audience. We do these calls via discord.
You can find the David Pakman show discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord for
everybody who's waiting to talk to me. Remember
in your nickname, you must have your name and
your location. So folks, I see with like just
a nickname or a handle or whatever, you aren't
going to be called on. Just so you know what the
what the guidelines are. For example, we will go
to Justin from New Jersey. Name and location and
that perfect format I mentioned. Justin from New
Jersey. Welcome. What's on your mind?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. First time
caller. I'm here, and I just wanted
to ask you a few quick questions.
Speaker 1: Sure. You have a
few questions. Interesting.
Speaker 2: First of all is do you watch any anime?
Speaker 1: I've only ever seen one anime movie. It
was like 15 years ago. It's called Spirited Away.
Speaker 2: I don't think I ever heard of that
book. All right. Into the political questions.
So do you think Ron DeSantis is actually not
going to run? Is that a possibility?
Speaker 1: I think it's a possibility,
but an unlikely one. I do believe
DeSantis is going to run. It is
very difficult to have a 19 point
win for governor for reelection,
to see yourself polling very well without even
having announced and then to get away from it,
because you never know when this opportunity
might present itself again. So I do think
DeSantis is ultimately going to run.
Speaker 2: Because I think it's
interesting because I can't see a world
where Trump doesn't win, honestly.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, I don't
just I also think the most likely
scenario is Trump wins the primary.
Speaker 2: Because I really do see him as
a very popular person, regardless of whether
it was DeSantis, Nikki Haley or Tim Scott. I
feel like the more people actually it just helps
Trump because he has a solid career compared to
these other people that don't.
Speaker 1: Where I am most.
Confident that Trump will best. DeSantis is one
if and when it becomes a national campaign with
the insults and the nicknames and the
rhetoric. DeSantis is so uncharismatic.
And even though there are Republican insiders
that are sick of Trump or never liked Trump. I
think the imagery of Trump making fun of DeSantis
and uncharismatic DeSantis not really being up to
the task of punching back I think is going to
be very tough for DeSantis to win. Very tough.
Speaker 2: I can agree with
that. Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: All right, Justin from
New Jersey, great to hear from you